Ouais.
Quand tu regardes les capacités actuelles, je pense que c'est
aussi une question très importante de se demander
quelle est la feuille de route — de savoir dans quelle mesure
ces systèmes s'améliorent
et à quel point les circuit
qu'on sera capable d'exécuter deviendront plus complexes
et pour ça, on a développé une métrique très importante
appelée le volume quantique
Parfois, tu peux lire ou entendre dans la presse grand public
le nombre de qubits, tu vois
comme mesure de progrès
Je te le dis franchement :
le simple nombre de qubits dans une machine n'est pas une
bonne mesure du progrès
Le progrès doit être mesuré par
le niveau de complexité du circuit que tu peux exécuter
les qubits de ces bonnes machines ne sont pas parfaits aujourd'hui
et ils présentent des erreurs introduites par le couplage
du système avec le monde extérieur
La puissance même de ces qubits —
l'intrication et ces propriétés —
les rend à la fois puissants
et fragiles face à l'interaction
et à la connexion avec le monde extérieur
Il faut donc réduire le taux d'erreur
tout en augmentant le nombre de qubits
C'est ce qui est représenté ici
Ce qu'on veut vraiment faire, c'est avancer en diagonale
et le volume quantique est une mesure qui incorpore
ces deux métriques ainsi que d'autres considérations clés